[Music]
named for a town in coastal Thailand sir
Raja is one of the world's most popular
hot sauces but what's inside the Crimson
condiment that makes it so pungently
popular for starters red jalapeno chili
peppers add a nice dash of spice thanks
to the mouth burning capsaicin a
compound that's actually an irritant to
mammals which explains why their heat is
on when it makes contact with the
trigeminal nerve in charge of conveying
temperature and pain to the brain but
garlic in sriracha
also activates a tri geminal receptor
specifically TRPA one the same protein
responsible for the sting of wasabi far
less irritating are the other five main
taste elements communicated directly to
your brain sweet salty sour bitter and
umami aka savory so for instance when
taste receptors encounter the sugar in
sriracha they instantly send your brain
of flood of messages with the hashtag
sweet as for the salt in the sauce it's
most likely detected by separate ion
channel receptors in your taste buds and
the same goes for distilled vinegar
which not only adds a tannin note to the
overall flavor profile but also extends
sriracha's shelf life while xanthan gum
helps the other ingredients cling to
your tongue the way the so called
rooster sauce clings to your food which
definitely gives your taste buds
something to crow about YUM
feeling wired yet subscribe